um though i think that the red pill is
actually very misunderstood
yeah well i think um i could say that
because i think a lot of the concepts i
didn't understand what you guys were
saying until like you especially i think
the most misunderstood person is rolo
tomasi yes because his concepts like
yeah you have to watch a lot of his con
content to really understand like what
he's talking about
um so like when i first got in the red
pill i'm like why do they call everyone
beta i'm like like like is that like i'm
like it's everyone i'm like jeff bezos
it's a beta like
well being a billionaire but then i
understand like they're talking about
like in that relationship very good it
doesn't mean he's a beta in every aspect
of his life
and what i understood like that concept
and then i think alpha just more of
leader right
yeah alpha alpha and beta are
it's there's a lot of shorthand
in the red pill community um alpha is
shorthand for a man who's a a man who's
a good leader he gets the intent i mean
men want to be him women want to be with
him
uh people gravitate toward him and he
also happens to be great with ladies
beta is shorthand for a man who's not so
uh who's not so good with ladies right
maybe a little less confident maybe a
little shorter now there are alpha men
who are short and guys who look like you
know the incredible hulk who are also i
guess you would call beta but alpha and
beta are just
and there are so many no man is totally
alpha or totally beta we're all
variations in between every man strives
to be more alpha than right
i mean i think that i think that goes
without saying but
but
you know there are so many people who
and again just to go back to detractors
they'll they'll use what they'll use
somebody's one beta trait as a
referendum on their overall character
well donovan loses his mind on the air
he's a bit okay fine if that's what you
think that's what you want to think it
is what it is i've never called myself
an alpha male am i an alpha male i don't
know probably not maybe uh
maybe a maybe a glorified beta male who
has more than you know more than the
average man whatever the case may be but
it's just shorthand for you know men who
men who are leaders and betas are men
who are followers
well and the other thing um
is just when talking about women like i
think women on the outside would not
really understand like what
like i remember i listened to one it was
the entrepreneurs and cars video
and they're like don't date her if she's
too friendly and i'm like damn i like to
chit chat is that like
is that gonna like disqualify is that a
bad thing you know like being friendly
but then like you understand it's more
like girls that are like
super um
friendly like tend to talk to more that
means her body count will probably be
higher and i'm like oh i could i could
like understand why they would think
that you know well i think it doesn't
and if it doesn't apply to you why does
it matter well i'll put it through this
way i think
he used the wrong word
women are supposed to be friendly being
friendly is also being feminine i think
what richard cooper and listen if this
is if this isn't what he meant then fine
but i think what i think what he was
trying to say is that if she is an
extroverted personality if she is the
life of the party if she is the shining
star
don't commit to her listen have your fun
with her but don't commit to her for
exactly what you just pointed out pearl
women who are extroverted women who are
always the life of the party women who
are outgoing and entertaining
they thrive on attention and when women
draw attention to themselves they are
going to get more male attention more
male attention equals more male dicks in
you at the end of the day now a lot of
people say well that isn't always the
case well sure it is look where we live
if women get attention women take
advantage of that that attention now
this is not an indictment on the female
species
men and women we can both be very
impulsive women tend to be even more
impulsive when it comes to male
attention i am never going to be the guy
who says that being a housewife is so
much more exciting than riding the
carousel but there are costs to both
right and so listen just because a girl
decides to listen i don't ever want to
get married i want to i want to uh i
want to sleep around hey listen no one's
going to no one's going to mad mouth her
decision but then on the back end you
can't expect to be taken seriously as a
wife or a long-term girlfriend if you
have that history so when a girl says
well i'm the life of the party and this
and the other
and i've been told this by many girls
that i've slept with okay great you're
the life of the party great we're gonna
have fun for a week or two but
eventually i'm gonna cut you off because
i know you're probably not a good
prospect because
your you get more attention as a natural
byproduct of your personality and that's
not that's not ragging on her that's not
kicking her to the curb that's just me
saying to myself okay extroverted women
tend to get more attention than
introverted girls not that introverted
girls never cheat because they do but
extroverted girls get more opportunities
and as american women have shown me
throughout my 44 plus years on the earth
the more attention a woman gets the more
body she tends to have